(casting)
Guys, 2018 is over,
and what a year it was for esports.
Now, you probably forgot half the sh-t that happened and to be honest, so did we.
That's why we have our interns hard at work collecting the best clips from 2018.
For this Best of we're making our way back through the year, month by month, by month.
No matter what esport you're into, whether it's  League of Legends, CS:GO, and everything in-between, we got you.
Now, with that being said, we couldn't include literally every sick clip from the year because this would be like a four hour video,
and I'm just not about it.
So let's pour one out for the clips that didn't make it.
Now that we got that out of the way, 2018 started with a bang,
with Cloud9 becoming the first ever North American team to win a Valve Major in Boston.
We also had PENTA esports securing their spot as the best Rainbow Six Siege roster in the game.
We had an incredible Spring Split from League of Legends, Dota 2 Majors, the Overwatch League, you name it.
Here's the best of what happened January to April.
(casting)
Well the start of 2018 was pretty sick, it was nothing compared to summer we had.
I mean think about it we had OG lifting the Aegis of Champions at what was potentially the best TI ever.
And who could forget the incredible EVO we had this summer.
Plus, plenty of CS:GO action, League of Legends, Rocket League, Rainbow Six, Overwatch, you name it.
Let's get into to with the best of May to August.
(casting)
Can you believe all of that happened in 2018, we're not even done this video yet.
Now, kicking off the final segment of this piece we have Astralis cementing themselves
as THE dominant roster in Counter-Strike with their win at the London Major.
We also saw the fall of Korean Dominance across multiple esports.
You had IG lifting the Summoners Cup at Worlds.
You had Serral winning at BlizzCon and so much more.
So here's the best of September to December 2018.
(casting)
Well guys, that was it.
That was 2018.
I'm going to be honest with you, it was a pretty sick year, and I don't think 2019 can hold a candle to it.
But I guess time will tell.
Now this is going to sound kind of corny, but my favorite part of the year was  seeing how you guys interact with our content.
So keep dropping those likes, keep leaving those comments into 2019.
And speaking of, let me know what your favorite moment from 2018 was in the comment section of this video
and I'll see you, next year.